Neues Jahr, neues Glück. Die zweite Bundesliga der Männer ist zurück aus der Winterpause. Und wir sind das auch. Über die Lage der Liga und speziell über die Situation bei Hertha BSC und Eintracht Braunschweig spreche ich jetzt mit Braunschweig-Legende Anna Lautner und Hertha-Experte Inge Böderling ganz viel Spaß. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Profis zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner. Und das Anzündung. Markus Kurt aus dem Revue. Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Lieben. Ja, anderthalb Monate ist es her, seitdem wir zuletzt auf die zweite Liga der Männer geblickt haben. Wir sind aber jetzt endlich zurück. Ich bin Eva-Lotta Bohle und ich hoffe erst mal, ihr verzeiht mir, dass es ja vor Weihnachten keine weitere Folge gab. Da hat Marc und mich das Berufs- und Privatleben dann doch ein bisschen eingeholt, so kurz vor Weihnachten. Aber wenn wir schon beim Housekeeping sind, der Rasenfunk. Er ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich durch eure Spenden und stellvertretend geht der Dank in dieser Folge an CL3. Timo, Machte, Burja, Felix, Gummel und Kühlschrank. Fantastischer Name. Ihr sorgt unter anderem dafür, dass ich hier sitze und dass ich aber durch diese Folge ja nicht alleine stolpern muss, sondern zwei Gästinnen mit dabei hab. Und zum einen ist das Anna Lautenbach, die ihr ja hoffentlich sowieso alle schon kennt, vor allem aus sämtlichen Braunschweig-Schwerpunkten hier im Rasenfunk. Hallo Anna, schön, dass du weiterhin, muss man ja auch einfach jedes Jahr sagen, in der Liga-Tour dabei bist.
Ja, das ist natürlich so Flankengeber generell. Das kann die Liga, komplette Liga wahrscheinlich einfach wirklich so ein Lied von singen. Freud mag sich bestimmt auch wahnsinnig darüber, dass Flanken einfach so ein schönes Ding sind in der zweiten Liga. Deshalb hat er das bestimmt auch an Marc und mich abgetreten. Nein, Spaß beiseite. Aber ja, es ist ja einfach zum Teil auch einfach wirklich irgendwie tragisch, weil du dir einfach, also die Spiele gegen Schalke fand ich irgendwie fast auch so ein bisschen beschreibend für die Saison. Also du machst es ja gar nicht mal so schlecht und dann, aber diese zweite Halbzeit, also dann verhaust du es dir. Du machst es sowieso glaube ich irgendwie bis zur roten Karte nicht gut. Und dann nach der roten Karte war ja sowieso einfach nur klar, okay, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie die restliche Zeit einfach durchstehen ohne Gegentor. Das haben sie geschafft, so klar. Da fand ich, hast du dann auch gesehen, da hat sich jeder Spieler irgendwie für jeden in diese Bälle geworfen und da muss man natürlich auch sagen, Schalke hat seine eigenen Probleme, das wissen wir auch. So, ich glaube da erzähle ich jetzt auch nichts Neues und ich will da auch nicht draufhauen, aber Leute guckt auf die Tabelle, ich erzähle euch da jetzt nicht, die waren so nicht was Neues und dann ist es ja einfach, also generell muss man ja auch immer diese XG-Werte mit viel Vorsicht genießen, aber wenn wir da einfach mal gucken, Husqvarth hatte ja immer diese Statistik so, wie viele Tore hätte man bisher schießen müssen, wie viele hätte man kassieren sollen und das ist schon, also da ist Braunschweig bei beiden, also sowohl quasi vor und against, relativ weit oben zu finden, was so die Differenz betrifft. Also man hat fast sieben Tore weniger geschossen als erwartet. Also man sollte zumindest an dieser 23-Tore-Marke kratzen. Ja, gucken wir mal zurück, wenn wir alleine immer von diesem ominösen 30. November sprechen, was das hätte bedeuten können, ganz viele Konjunktive und gleichzeitig hat man halt fast viel zu viel kassiert, was auch relativ weit oben ist, tatsächlich einfach in diesem Vergleich und das kommt dann natürlich irgendwie alles noch dazu. Gleichzeitig, wir haben schon über Preußen Münster beispielsweise gesprochen, die klar, die wussten von Anfang an, da geht es nur um Abstiegskampf und die dann natürlich, also so wie ein Elversberg nach oben hin die Ruhe hat, vielleicht hat halt ein Preußen Münster nach unten, vielleicht nicht direkt dieses und wir haben es in den letzten Jahren gesehen, meistens schafft es zumindest einen Aufsteiger immer drin zu bleiben. Ja, also es wird halt irgendwie nicht leichter.
Ne, absolut nicht. Also das, was mich halt wirklich so ratlos macht, ist wir spielen jetzt gegen Magdeburg Freitagabend und was haben die richtig gemacht, was wir so falsch gemacht haben? Ja, wahrscheinlich hätten wir vielleicht nicht ins Härtel wollen sollen für ein halbes Jahr, der jetzt mit Aue gegen Hannover 2 verliert. Ja, okay, aber das finde ich schon langfristig kalt, irgendwie Leistungsträger zu binden und dann den Kader wirklich smart zu verstärken. Ich meine nichts für ungut, aber wenn jetzt irgendwie im Winter darüber gesprochen wird, ob wir noch einen Innenverteidiger verpflichten, da greife ich mir schon kurz an den Kopf, weil ich denke, ja, ich verstehe das, die Innenverteidiger sind nicht gut in Form, aber ich glaube, wir haben sieben. Also irgendwann ist halt auch mal gut so. Dann müsst ihr halt dafür sorgen, dass die, dass die wieder in Form kommen. Aber ja.
Also ich verfolge Braunschweig jetzt nicht intensivst, wenn sie nicht gerade die nächste Gegner von Hertha BSC sind. Aber ich habe im Vorfeld der Folge heute auch so ein bisschen die Berichterstattung gescannt und habe da den lustigen Fakt gefunden, dass Braunschweig tatsächlich eine der kontastärksten Mannschaften der Liga ist und auch mit drei Kontertoren zu den Top 4 der Liga gehören fand ich irgendwie. Das ist vielleicht auch nicht so schild. Das stimmt, aber ich fand es trotzdem ganz spannend, dass es tatsächlich offensichtlich bis ganz vorne und das bestätige ich ja so ein bisschen, was du gerade gesagt hast, dass da vorne dann irgendwie der fehlt, der den Rest macht, sag ich mal, bis zum Strafraum eigentlich alles ganz gut läuft und das passt auch zu dem, was du gesagt hast, Eva, mit den Expected Goals, dass man halt dann doch vielleicht eigentlich sieben machen müssen, aber da vorne fehlt es dann wahrscheinlich einfach, oder?
Ja, also Philipp ist ein überragender Stürmer und nicht zu Unrecht. Hat sich jetzt Mainz auch da in der Winterpause angenähert. Ich bin sehr, sehr froh, dass wir dem wieder stehen konnten. Es stand kurz zur Debatte, ob man Philipp Richtung Bundesliga verkauft und dann für die Rückserie wenigstens ausleitet, weil sein Vertrag im Sommer aller Voraussicht nach, also ich glaube, es gibt irgendwie eine Klausel bei Klassenerhalt, verlängert er sich nochmal. Aber natürlich hättest du jetzt im Winter mehr für ihn bekommen, als du es dann noch im Sommer tun wirst. Ich hatte so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass ich da argumentativ so ein bisschen was auch gerne zurechtgelegt wird. Also wir sind keine Mannschaft, die besonders viel mit dem Ball anfangen kann. Wir spielen gerne mit wenig Ballbesitz. Wir sind gerne die bisschen zurückgezogenere Mannschaft, was nicht heißt, dass man irgendwie wenig läuft oder dass keine Aufwände betrieben werden oder so. Aber grundsätzlich liegt uns das Konterspiel schon mehr. Aber dann warst du in einer Situation, in der du das ganz ordentlich gemacht hast, in der die Ergebnisse auch gestimmt haben, zum Beispiel gegen Hannover und gegen den HSV. Die beiden von drei Siegen in der Hinserie. Und dann hast du gegen schwächere Mannschaften gespielt und dann hieß es ja, das liegt uns nicht so sehr, da müssen wir zu sehr das Spiel machen und wir können nicht kontern. Und dann hat man aber auch gegen die erfolgreicheren Mannschaften nicht mehr erfolgreich gespielt. Und dann hieß es ja, aber die sind halt auch so gut, da funktioniert es dann nicht. Also dass du so ein bisschen, dass du sich einfach so ein bisschen gebunden hast in deinen eigenen Argumenten. Und ich muss sagen, ich bin auch einfach, ich bin so ein bisschen aufgebraucht, was das angeht. Wir stehen da jetzt unten, die Dritteliga winkt schon wieder sehr energisch.
Kann ich nicht empfehlen an der Stelle nochmal.
Nee, auch auf der anderen Seite denkst du, ich bin eh so bei der Telekom unter Vertrag, dann kann ich hier Samstag wenigstens um 14 Uhr Fußball gucken und muss mich nicht in diese Sky-Maschinerie reinbegeben.
Oder du musst sonntags abends zu Stuttgart 2.
Ja gut, ohne Scheiß. Wenn 96.2 die Klasse hält, dann können wir nicht absteigen, dann möchte ich, das wäre wirklich die Ultra-Denütigung, gegen Hannover 2 in der dritten Liga spielen zu müssen. Oh mein Gott. Na ja, egal.
Einmal kurz jegliche romantische Gedanken über die dritte Liga wieder. Hey, bin ich gerne immer für zuständig.
Ja, aber ganz im Ernst, wir stehen jetzt das dritte Jahr da ganz unten. Und irgendwann spürst du das einfach nicht mehr. Das ist also ganz im Ernst, kann ich hier jetzt auch nicht drei Jahre in Panik irgendwie verfallen. So das sind ja. Ja, was soll ich jetzt dazu sagen? So ich will natürlich nicht absteigen, aber die Möglichkeit ist da. Und irgendwie denke ich auch, ich würde mich halt auch nicht wundern.
Also Anna, du bist einfach dieses Meme von diesem Hund in diesem brennenden Haus oder in diesem brennenden Zimmer und du hast aber so einen Feuerlöscher in der Hand und dann machst du zwischendurch mal so ein unmotiviertes so. Das ist halt beeindruckt, braunschweig in die Gipfel.
Ja absolut total. Ja ich weiß keine Ahnung, ich meine du gehst ja auch eh hin so. Das ist ja dein Verein. Das muss ich dir ja auch nicht erzählen Eva. Wenn man denkt immer so, das ist alles scheiße und am nächsten Wochenende ärgert man sich trotzdem oder freut sich noch schlimmer.
Dann fährt man doch wieder nach Sandhausen oder so. Ja super. Ja ich finde es halt einfach keine Ahnung, ich finde es einfach super schwierig das dann auch irgendwie zu erklären. Also wie, weil irgendwie keine Ahnung, wir reden immer darüber, ja okay irgendwann kann es nicht mehr der Trainer sein. Dann wenn es nicht der Trainer sein kann, guckt man auf die sportlichen Verantwortlichen. Da haben wir letztes Jahr auch in Genüge drüber geguckt. Da haben wir eigentlich gesagt, okay da ist man eigentlich den besseren Weg inzwischen eingeschlagen, aber trotzdem ist es ja so. Und das darf man natürlich, das muss man natürlich auch noch mal ganz klar sagen, wenn dann eben gesagt wird, ja warum können die und die, die Transfers machen und wir machen die nicht. Ja lass uns als Beispiel Elversberg nehmen, ja die müssen halt, also wir haben es hier diskutiert im Dezember, ja warum muss Elversberg im Winter keine Topspieler verkaufen? Weil dann da doch finanziell eine andere Kraft hintersitzt und das darf man, wie ich auch finde, immer nicht vergessen und natürlich wenn ein Spieler sich entscheiden muss zwischen, sagen wir doch mal Münster und Braunschweig, ja dann sagst du okay, da haben wir einen Aussteiger, das ist das und das, okay das haben die in den letzten drei Jahren erreicht, das ist das Ziel, das ist die spielerische Identität, okay spiele ich da Abstiegskampf oder spiel ich mit Eintracht Braunschweig Abstiegskampf? Und das ist ja einfach von den Namen her, ja also glaube ich jetzt nicht, dass da die beiden Städte jetzt irgendwie gut Münster, Studistadt, aber ich meine per se einfach vom, wo die beiden Vereine stehen, aber das ist natürlich auch super schwierig irgendwann, weil du natürlich irgendwann keine Verhandlungsgrundlage mehr hast, und das ist glaube ich dann einfach so ein Rabbit Hole, aus dem du dann, wenn du eben nicht finanziell da irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, die stärkste Kraft denn da ist, auch einfach irgendwann nicht mehr rauskommst. So und dann kann man immer sagen, ja vielleicht müssen wir dann endlich mal absteigen. Ja, das hat der HSV auch gesagt. Und dann sehen wir ja auch, wie das auch nach fünf Jahren so läuft. So und das ist halt so, deshalb keine Ahnung, es hat ja echt lange gedauert, an und bis wir dich jetzt wieder eingeladen haben, nicht weil wir dich hier nicht haben wollen, aber weil es ja auch einfach so schwierig ist.
Es ändert sich halt nichts. Also wir haben es im Vorgespräch ja auch gesagt, was sagen wir jetzt heute? Das wir in der letzten Sendung nicht auch gesagt haben. Und ich wünschte, ich könnte irgendwie, aber ihr seht mich in ratloser Blüte. Ich habe keine Ahnung, weil ich auch denke, ja klar, kannst du den Trainer entlassen, kannst du den Sportvorstand irgendwie wechseln, kannst du einen Spieler holen, aber irgendwie. Ehrlich gesagt habe ich das Gefühl, jetzt große Veränderungen anzustreben. Das wäre eher Show. Da sind wir wieder bei so Quickfix.
Ja.
Weiß ich nicht, habe ich kein gutes Gefühl mit.
Also es gab ja die Beispiele, wo man in der Hinrunde nicht gut gespielt hat. Und die Rückrunde, die hat man, also gab es von Vereinen in der zweiten Liga. Also war ja ganz, ganz oft der Fall, dass du irgendwie einen Verein hattest, der hat Winterpause, hat irgendwie enorm gestruggelt. Rückrunde enorm viele Punkte geholt und auf diesem Gerüst wurde dann einfach was gebaut. Und dann ist man nächstes Jahr aufgestiegen. So gab es ja irgendwie mit St. Pauli, mit Boche, mit Bielefeld. So da gab es ja auch zwischendurch irgendwie mit Heiden einmal. Da gab es ja genug Vereine, die dann immer so kurz unten dran gekratzt haben. Da hat man Veränderungen gemacht. Aber auch das ist ja alles irgendwie so Punkte, wo man sagt, ja aber die Voraussetzungen musst du erstmal haben. Ich finde das dann irgendwie, also kann das auch irgendwie verstehen, dass das als Fan dann auch irgendwie so ist. Und jetzt kommen halt Magdeburg, Köln und Ulm. Zwei dieser Top-Vereine und dann ein Mitkandidat im Abstiegskampf. Das ist eigentlich das, was du nicht haben willst jetzt.
Nee, das ist richtig. Gegen die Mitabstiegskandidaten müssen wir uns dringend besser schlagen als in der Hinrunde. Da haben wir gegen keinen einzigen gewinnen können, also gegen Fürth, aber Fürth war damals noch kein Mitabstiegskandidat, sondern eigentlich relativ gut oben noch mit dabei. Auch krass tatsächlich, wie die abgeschmiert sind. Habe ich so echt nicht kommen sehen, weil die so gut gestartet sind eigentlich im Sommer. Also du musst halt zu Hause irgendwie einen Ansatz von Stabilität finden, weil ich nicht glaube, dass du so viele Punkte brauchst. Ich meine, das hilft dir auch langfristig nicht weiter, wenn du jetzt schon wieder mit dem Bare-Minimum planst, aber du musst irgendwie in der Liga bleiben. Dritte Liga ist keine Option. Das ist finanziell, haben wir uns davon einfach nach wie vor nicht erholt. Um dir ein bisschen Mut zu machen für die nächsten Jahre.
Ja, freu ich mich. Hier ist auch schon mal wieder Untergangsstimmung von daher. Ich liebe Fußball. Ich sag's einfach gerne nochmal. Ich finde es immer schön, dass es immer so kleine Therapiesitzungen für alle Menschen sind. Das ist einfach immer toll. Es ist einfach schön, dass wir das haben können. Aber ich bin mal wirklich gespannt. Wir haben ja sowohl dann doch auch einen relativ engen Abstiegskampf mal wieder, weil diese Liga dann ja wirklich an diesem zwölften Platz dann... Also gefühlt kann es ja trotzdem irgendwie sein, wenn weiß ich nicht, Braunschweig jetzt die nächsten zehn Spiele gewinnt, dann können sie auch siebter werden. So ungefähr.
Die Serie.
Das ist einfach so.
Und das ist einfach so absurd. Und ich weiß, ich sag das zum Ende jeder Folge, ich sag immer so, das ist einfach absurd. Ich habe höchsten Respekt vor jedem Menschen, der in dieser Liga arbeitet. Ich sag's immer wieder. Ich sitze hier immer gemütlich in meinem Sessel und sag so, muss ja einfach alles irgendwie einfacher gehen. Aber ist es einfach nicht und das sieht man einfach. Und man kann einfach und das will ich nochmal betonen, glaube ich Eintritt Braunschalke gerade irgendwie nicht schlechte Arbeit vorwerfen oder so. Aber da scheinen auch genug Leute zu wissen, dass vielleicht irgendwann einfach die eigenen Mittel ausgeschöpft sind.
Du siehst, ich glaube das beste Beispiel ist jetzt tatsächlich dieser Torhüter, der einfach zurückkommt, weil auch er sich in der zweiten Liga verkalkuliert hat. Hoffmann dachte, er geht zur Schalke, er dachte, ich spiele und er dachte, Schalke sichere Adresse in der zweiten Liga. Ich spiele nächstes Jahr Bundesliga, kein Problem. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich hab immer noch mal gedacht, smart, mach das, es ist einfach klug. Genauso wirst du erfolgreicher Bundesliga-Torhüter. Ja, wir kommen zurück in Braunschweig.
Ich finde, davon gibt es aber einige Spieler. Ich finde, es gibt viele, die sagen, wir wechseln in die zweite Liga, weil da können wir uns auch ein bisschen etablieren und schon mal Richtung Bundesliga schnuppern. Und dann kommen sie hierhin, sehen die zweite Liga und denken sich so ganz anders, als ich gedacht hätte und können sich eben nicht durchsetzen und haben große Probleme und gehen dann doch wieder ins Ausland. Also ich finde, die zweite Liga, die ist echt so ein bisschen Brennglas und Vorstufe. Und da scheitern schon recht viele.
Gut, aber wer bei Schalke auch dachte, da ist endlich mal Konstanz auf dem Trainerbestell angekommen. Also es tut mir leid, das musst du doch einfach, das Risiko musst du eingehen. Das ist ja jetzt irgendwie schon wieder der Gefühl, 50. Trainer auf dem Trainerstuhl. Also total. Das ist einfach, das gehört natürlich auch zur Geschichte dazu. Das Gespräch, was er geführt hat. Die sind ja alle nicht mehr da. Mit den Rondorben-Hoffmarschen im Sommer, die Gespräche geführt hat, da ist keiner mehr von da.
Da ist schon einer mehr.
Auch einfach super tragisch.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, dass über die Personalie wirklich auch mit einem weinenden Augengespräch, ich find's cool, dass er wieder da ist. Ich glaube, dass uns das weiterhelfen wird. Ich glaube aber auch, hätte, wäre konjunktiv, dass wir, wenn er sich nicht hätte locken lassen, jetzt besser dastehen würden.
Ja. Mensch. Tragisch.
Ja, finde ich schon, finde ich schon, ja. Aber auch das, keine Ahnung, vielleicht auch nicht. Vielleicht, man weiß es nicht, man kann es ja nicht überprüfen.
Um Luther Matthäus zu zitieren, wäre, wäre Fahrradkette.
Ja, der große Philosoph. Der große Philosoph.
Ich dachte ja auch nicht nochmal, dass er heute in dieser Folge noch Erwähnung findet. Ich glaube, das ist auch einfach ein guter Punkt, um jetzt zu sagen, wir beenden das an dieser Stelle. Wenn Luther schon seinen koten Mann hier gegeben hat, den viel zumindest als Zitatgeber, können wir das an der Stelle auch beenden. Ich bedanke mich ganz, ganz herzlich bei Inga, die zum ersten Mal im Rasenfunk dabei war. Vielen lieben Dank für deine Einblicke in die Welt von Hertha BSC. Schön, dass du dabei warst.
Sehr gerne, vielen Dank.
Und natürlich auch lieben Dank an Anna. Also ich hoffe, es war zumindest trotzdem schön für dich.
Ja, es ist immer schön.
Das freut uns. Und wir werden ja sehen, ob wir uns nächstes Jahr, diese Zeitpunkt vielleicht um Eintracht Braunschweig Ausstiegskandidat werden.
Ah, da krieg ich direkt Ziemtus.
And it's here first.
Vielleicht auch Aufstiegskandidat in der dritten Liga. Das muss auch komisch an mich zu sehen.
Viele fällt bin dad und dad.
Ja, richtig. Gut, dann lieben Dank auch, dass ihr in diese Folge reingehört habt. Wir sind höchstwahrscheinlich in zwei Wochen wieder da, unter anderem höchstwahrscheinlich auch da endlich mal wieder mit dem HSV. Beruhigt euch, liebe Leute, er kommt endlich dran. Ich weiß, ihr wartet alle drauf. Sonst wünsche ich euch bis dahin ganz viel Spaß mit Zweitliga-Fußball und bis bald. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.